Grazie
[Applauso]
passo sinistro
passo destro
passione
fiducia
Spesso siamo concentrati
focalizzati preoccupati
del nostro futuro
che dimentichiamo e annulliamo il nostro
presente lo riduciamo a nulla
se questo pensiero risuona in voi invito
tutti a condividere adesso un esercizio
un esercizio piccolo semplice come
quello di chiudere gli occhi
concentriamoci sul nostro respiro
concentriamoci sull'area che entra e che
esce dal nostro naso
siamo lì
all'estremità delle nostre narici
come un vigile urbano che fa entrare e
uscire aria dal nostro naso
e adesso
accediamo alla parte più profonda del
nostro cervello
e in mente ripetiamo per ogni respiro
che siamo qui sono qui
ora lentamente
riapriamo gli occhi
guardiamo quello che ci circonda
guardiamo le altre persone
guardiamo gli altri esseri viventi fuori
alla finestra guardiamo gli oggetti con
la consapevolezza
che ci ascoltano che l'universo ci
ascolta che l'universo interagisce con
noi
Come stai
ora siamo qui
bene di norma Io parlo di fiducia parlo
continuamente di fiducia perché fiducia
è quella moneta che scambiamo
continuamente la moneta che scambiamo
nel quotidiano e la moneta con che io
scambio con la mia famiglia con i miei
amici con i colleghi con gli sconosciuti
ma oggi
si parla di passione
si parla di passione e passione e quella
roba che
Se ce l'hai pensi di avere tutto
e senza credi di essere niente
niente
è un tema estremamente scivoloso
passione Ma dato che sono stato invitato
a questo Teddy ne devo parlare quindi ho
iniziato a rifletterci ho iniziato a
riflettere su fiducia e passione
le impronte che ho messo sul palco
Quando sono salito piede destro piede
sinistro
fiducia e passione e ho capito che un
po' come gli emisferi del nostro
cervello
Se portate in equilibrio
passione e fiducia possono evocare
quello che il nostro demone il nostro
demone interiore
e ho capito
che non conta quale sia la passione
ne possiamo prendere una a caso
spesso ne abbiamo diverse una due tre
quattro cinque sei una
non conta quale prendiamo conta
l'esercizio quello quotidiano quello
piccolo quell'estenuante
quello invisibile
quello inutile
quello con pochi risultati per gli altri
conta l'esercizio
quello che ci consente di imparare e
implementare velocemente nel quotidiano
quello che ho imparato
è che l'universo mi ha fatto un grande
dono
mi ha dato un grande credo mi ha dato
una grande certezza Anzi ci ha dato una
grande certezza
il disordine e il disordine
quello dell'incertezza e anche quello
delle camerette
quelle delle camerette dei giochi perché
lì nelle camerette dei giochi che il
tempo si trasforma e lì nelle camerette
dei giochi in cui iniziavo nuove
avventure e lì le camerette dei giochi
che ho sempre avuto con me
il mio mantello
il mantello
chi conosce di voi questo mantello
per me
è stato il mantello dell'invisibilità
e il mantello che indosso ogni giorno e
il mantello è stato il mio mezzo con cui
andare in giro per il mondo il mantello
è stato il mio mezzo con cui interagire
con l'universo il mantello è stato il
mio mezzo con cui
esercitavo la fiducia
e mantello di passione hanno qualcosa di
comune di molto forte
perché ho crescendo ho capito
che la passione non è nient'altro una
scusa
una scusa come il mantello una scusa per
andare in giro per il mondo
una scusa per osservare il mondo una
scusa per interagire col mondo ma scusa
per imparare tutto quello che non
conosciamo
una scusa per fare tutto quello mai
fatto prima
una scusa per tuffarsi nell'ignoto
Ecco la passione
come il mantello
ti permette di esplorare la vita senza
preoccuparti di come ti vedono
ti permette di andare dove il mondo ti
direbbe di no
invece
per evocare il nostro demone potremmo
aspettare 120 anni La nostra naturale
durata delle cellule
Potremmo lasciare prima il corpo e poi
scoprire il nostro demone
Non abbiamo fretta per il demone
concentriamoci sul logico concentriamoci
sul presente
respiriamo
Ed ora che siamo concentrati sul
presente rovistiamo nel cassetto
cambiamo mantello Ci sono diversi
mantelli quello più piccolo quello più
largo chissà come vestono non
preoccupiamocene prendiamone uno
occupiamoci di prendere un mantello non
preoccupiamoci
troppo del futuro concentriamoci e
occupiamoci del presente prendendo un
mantello proviamo lo vestiamolo se non
va bene lo cambiamo lo cambiamo domani
Ma quando lo avremmo cambiato abbiamo
imparato qualcosa di nuovo
abbiamo imparato qualcosa di nuovo
perché quel mantello ci ha consentito di
farci dell'ignoto
ho voluto concretizzare queste mie
parole con fondando Aurora fellos
Aurora fellose è un ente no profit
che opera in tutto il Mediterraneo in
tutta Europa e con Aurora vogliamo dare
Mantelli
vogliamo scambiare mantelle
abbiamo creato una community di ragazzi
Under 23 che volano in giro per il mondo
con i loro mantelli che fanno fino alle
4 di notte scambiando mantengo gli altri
facendo entrare gli altri nelle proprie
passioni e facendo scoprire nuove
passioni e gli altri
senza il peso il sentirsi in colpa di
cambiare mantello di cambiare passione
senza sentire il peso di imparare
perché quando impariamo cambiamo
e così che questa community di fellos
gli Aurora fellos spinti dalla curiosità
vanno in giro per il mondo si
confrontano tra di loro penso
a una ragazza del quinto liceo che è
salita è stata imbarcata su una nave
militare e per alcuni giorni è andata in
giro per il Mediterraneo ma a fare
cetacei
penso a un ragazzo laureato in economia
che ha detto io voglio essere Prima di
tutto un viaggiatore
E allora è andato in giro per tutta
Europa per 90 giorni Zaino in spalla e
ora sta ripartendo per un nuovo viaggio
di 90 giorni
penso a un ragazzo che è volato in
Africa ha detto voglio capire di più
voglio mettere le mani in passo sulla
sostenibilità energetica dei villaggi
Fatemi sperimentare
è il mio mantello farò qualcosa nella
sostenibilità dei villaggi in futuro Non
lo so Ma fatemi sperimentare oggi
come penso a un'altra ragazza che volata
negli Stati Uniti per coltivare la
propria passione Quella è la fotografia
e così che andate in giro per tutti i
marchi americani spetta
colari negli ultimi 20 anni
mi sono immerso in diversi mantelli Ho
vestito diversi mantelli mi sono immerso
in diverse passioni
e i miei mezzi sono stati
la musica lo sviluppo web il web
marketing la consulenza strategica
le avanguardie educative il venture
Capital
ogni volta che intrapreso una di queste
passioni le ho fatte
al massimo dei miei interessi non al
massimo delle mie potenzialità al
massimo dei miei interessi potenzialità
e passione non sono cose che camminano
sempre insieme
ma credo fortemente che quando hai una
passione Come diceva qualcuno prima di
me bisogna sfruttare quell'occasione per
portare al massimo dei tuoi interessi
quello che fai e così che potrai
imparare di più e poi cambiarla il prima
possibile magari il prima possibile può
essere dopo 80 anni o dopo 10 o dopo uno
o dopo un giorno
penso a quando ho iniziato a studiare
clarinetto
ho iniziato a studiare clarinetto e mio
fratello mi dice Jacopo Ma che lo fai a
fare perché perdi tempo chi fa fare
clarinetto tanto un paio di mesi e cambi
dopo sei mesi e riscritto al
conservatorio
studiavo oboe oboec clarinetto sono due
strumenti a fiato sono
completamente diversi
ma completamente Cioè è come dire
pianoforte violino hanno solo in Comune
il fiato
Ok quindi il Papa ha ragione mio
fratello ma anche no
perché la musica mi ha dato la capacità
di stare in equilibrio col mondo oggi
non sono
in un'orchestra
ma uno non
esercita una passione
per suonare in un'orchestra esercito
passione per arrivare ad un risultato
Ignoto e quello che mi ha dato la musica
e l'equilibrio col mondo
quello che
ti dà una passione non lo si scopre
mentre la si sviluppa mentre la si fa
mentre la si esercita lo si scopre in
futuro quando hai tutti quei puntini che
inizi a connettere tra di loro
e così che ho deciso di confondare
moonstone
moonstone come Pietra di Luna
ho deciso di farlo
perché volevo consentire a tutto il
nostro team di andare ogni sera Fieri ed
integri del nostro lavoro
Fieri ed integri di credere dare fiducia
alle passioni dei fondatori più
ambiziosi in Europa
I fondatori di aziende che esercitano le
loro passioni
attraverso lo sviluppo la creazione
imprenditoriale di organizzazioni di
azienda
e così che comunque sono abbiamo
investito
in fondatori che stanno sviluppando una
batteria
quantistica un accumulatore di energia
quantistica
e così con moonstone abbia investito su
un team di fondatori che lavora
per terapie digitali per aumentare la
salute del nostro cervello
e così con mouston utilizziamo un nostro
piede di oggi la nostra fiducia
unendola alle passioni per far emergere
i demoni le vocazioni
le risposte che spesso riceviamo il
giorno prima dell'ultimo respiro
fiducia e passione per
sviluppare i luoghi che abiteranno i
nostri figli
i nostri nipoti
quello che so
di quello che ho imparato fino ad oggi
nella mia sperimentazione chiamata vita
no quando nasciamo Facciamo una cosa
iniziare a respirare iniziamo a
sperimentare la vita e quello che ho
capito
e che spesso sperimentando le diverse
passioni potremmo incontrare qualche
gabbia potremo incontrare qualche Sì
detto male potremmo incontrare qualche
no detto male è l'unico segreto è
rinegoziare il prima possibile
tornare indietro il prima possibile
negoziare quel no che volevamo dire Sì
quel sì che volevamo dire no perché quel
no quel sì
diventano una palla di neve che corre
verso di noi ogni giorno ingigantisce
sempre di più
è molto semplice
andiamo a sciogliere
semplifichiamo sciogliamo quel nodo
sciogliamo quella palla di neve
La vita
è fatta per essere liberi per volare per
sognare per sperimentare E per cambiare
per cambiare passione
Io sono un equivoco Mi chiamo Jacopo
perché la probabilità della mia nascita
è inferiore a un miliardesimo
vorrei dire che tutti voi siete equivoci
ma non ho questa confidenza
però
a grandi linee su per giù nessuno di noi
ha scelto il proprio DNA
la foto qualcuno
Ok
non ho detto niente
tutto quello che so è che quello
che mi è successo
è dovuto all'equilibrio della voglia di
determinare
di determinare qualcosa unito al caos
dell'universo
determinare qualcosa unito al caos
e questo è quello che so
e so anche che il risultato di
determinare qualcosa ogni tal caso
dell'universo ha un risultato è
risultato è sempre ignoto
è sempre diverso alle aspettative sopra
sotto è ignoto
per questo oggi ti vedo le mie passioni
i miei Mantelli
E capisco che non sono mai state la
destinazione
ma mezzi con cui
respirare sentire vivere
Grazie
[Applauso]